what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 26th of july
the joint is brought to you by relief
band
did you know a third of americans
regularly suffer from nausea
listen man i don't really have nausea
but
when i had the surgery after the surgery
was when i got the nausea
from the pain pills i didn't know what
to do but before i got my surgery
i got a box in the mail and it was
relief banned listen
i didn't even know what a relief ban was
i thought i kept
i called the doctor's office i called
everybody that
did you send me a relief ban i called
bob lalingas nobody knew who sent me a
relief ban
then one day my agent called me she goes
hey did you get the relief ban i go
jesus christ how did you even know i was
gonna have surgery she goes i didn't
i just sent it to you they wanted they
wanted you to [__] read their uh
lines on the show so i was like
oh my god this is tremendous i put the
[__] the relief band on
and i was excited as [__] no nausea
during my
i had like two bouts of nausea from the
pain pills and that was because i was in
the car
driving relief ban helped me with the
[__] nausea relief ban
is the number one fda cleared
anti-nausea wristband
that has been clinically proven to
relief and prevent
nausea and vomiting the product is a
hundred
percent drug free here's how it works
relief ban
stimulates a nerve in the wrist that
travels to the part of the brain
that controls nausea it tells it to
block the brain
from sending your stomach the signal
when you're sick
it's [__] science relief band is the
only over-the-counter
wearable band that has been used in
hospitals and oncology clinics to treat
nausea
and vomiting listen to me i love relief
ban
it helped me tremendously during the
surgery
to ensure nausea is never the reason to
miss out
on life's important no moments right now
relief band has an exclusive offer
for uncle joy's joint listeners if
you're gonna have surgery
or you suffer from nausea or you just
you know if you go to reliefband.com and
use promo code joey
you'll receive twenty percent off for
free shipping
and no questions asked about a 30-day
money-back guarantee
relief ban r-e-l-i-e-n
dot com use promo code joy for 20
off and get relief from the nausea it's
summertime
you don't want to have nausea now so get
reliefband.com
use promo code joey and get 20
off free shipping and no questions asked
30 day
money back guarantee reliefband.com
i love it the joint is also brought to
you by magnesium breakthrough
if you're a man you got to go to the
doctor you know me i don't like the
doctor
i don't like needles but i had to get
blood this week i had to go to doctor
this week
listen if you're ignoring how you feel
you need to listen to me
fatigue anxiety headaches all might come
back to one thing
you're not getting enough magnesium
listen magnesium breakthrough
is the cure it's tremendous magnesium is
an amazing mineral not only does it help
you sleep it also helps root reduce
stress
maintain a regular heartbeat and boost
immunity
i love this product i have been using it
for two or three months now and i sleep
like a baby you see there's only four of
them in here right
there's only like maybe four or three of
them left because i eat these
two for breakfast and two a half hour
before
i go to bed remember one thing eighty
percent of the population
is magnesium deficit deficient even my
wife
went on this if you don't get the right
amounts you're eventually going to end
up at the doctor's office i did
so do me a favor i'm amazed on how much
better i sleep
and how rested i feel in the morning
magnesium breakthrough is the only
organic supplement that includes seven
unique forms of magnesia so do me a
favor
just for my listeners go to
magbreakthrough.com
again i'm gonna write it for you i'm
gonna spell it for you m-a-g
breakthrough b-r-e-a-k-t-h-r-o-g-u-g-h
dot com slash joey use code joey 10
again that's joey tender and check out
to save 10 percent
that's the magbreakthrough.com joey
use code joey10 for 10 off
and when you see the sandman tell them
uncle joey sent you listen
magnesium breakthrough is tremendous i
love it
you're gonna love it no more fatigue no
more anxiety
and no more headaches right now go to
magnesium magbreakthrough.com
joey i'm going to give you 10 off when
you put joey 10 in there
you hear me magbreakthrough.com joey
you're gonna love it
let's get this party started
[Music]
it's uncle joey's joint coming at you
next to the relief band
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
welcome to a beautiful
monday july the 26th we got one more
week left in the year
and out of the year the [__] month
and that's it this [__] summer is
cooking [__] like i knew it
would
i knew this summer was gonna move just
think about it next sunday
will be two months to the release of the
[__] sopranos
so it's moving [__] fast it's real
and it's on [__] i've been having
a great time lately
uh i feel good until this afternoon when
i go back
and they're gonna do the left side
they're gonna [__] rip it up
and uh whatever but like i said i'm
getting i called them up and told them i
was traumatized
so i'm gonna get a little [__]
laughing gas not the reefer i don't
smoke before the dentist
don't forget the support laughing gas
you guys are [__] it's almost done
it's almost done the new [__] stock
will be out in 10 days but uh
please keep supporting ziki the weed is
[__] tremendous
i was telling mike i'm starting to get
[__] blitzed
blitzed friday [__] night my wife and
daughter went out to a fair
i got home about 6 30 there was no
dinner you know i'm like
i'm not really that hungry i go you know
what man i've been getting
i've been getting to the point i've been
getting so [__] stoned that night
that i got to be honest with you guys i
[__]
i go upstairs remember when i used to do
the stories on rogan about the [__]
uh
the [__] cheese doodles how i would
stop i couldn't stop eating them and i'd
wake up in the morning
and there'd be [__] pirates booty
everywhere i'm not eating the pirates
booty
but i'm [__] eating at night not big
meals not like l.a
sandwiches there's no salami there's no
prosciutt i told my wife not to buy no
cheese nothing
it's apples it's protein bars it's uh
[__] friday night i had a bagel i had
a cinnamon bagel
with butter i was so [__] hungry so
i'm not eating like meals
i'm just eating a little something to go
to bed and i'm sleeping like a [__]
champ
look at me i'm losing weight i'm still
on the [__]
i got nine more pounds and i can fight
in the ufc can you [__] believe that
nine more pounds i'm 270 [__] four
i'm squeezing them out one at a time but
who gives a [__] uh my gums got swollen
again over the [__] weekend so i
i don't know what the [__] is going on
my health is good
i'm feeling good and what i want to talk
to you guys about
is something that i've read lately a lot
i'm getting a lot of messages from
people
it's been a long time and i knew it that
this pandemic because i went through it
a lot of people picked up bad habits
during this [__] pandemic
we discussed this a few weeks ago but
wow i'm getting calls from dear friends
of mine
that are coming clean now telling me
what they went through the [__]
pandemic
i had a buddy from colorado who i speak
to
who's been clean from cocaine longer
than i have
and he [__] relapsed during the
pandemic like
last november he just called me about a
week ago and came clean with me that he
had to go back to a [__] rehab
because i talk to him
like every two weeks he's a dear friend
of mine from when i started comedy
uh he's never been on the podcast
nothing like that he's a [__]
electrician you know
but uh we're dear friends i love him to
death but when he [__] told me
because
he was the one that tried to help me get
off the [__] coke
when i got off it back in 2000 [__]
seven
you know he was making calls for me he's
like you sure you don't want to go to a
rehab he was captain rehab at the time
by the way
you know those dudes that [__] get
clean and go all in this is why i'm in
[__] shock
but i guess this pandemic [__] just
he said he was bored
and he went to a kid's house that
he shouldn't have been at his house and
the kid whipped out some coke
and he said that he watched the guy do
it and they thought about it for two
days it's [__] weird because i tell
you what somebody hit me up the other
day and was
asking me throughout this whole period
that i've been going through whatever i
was going through
that it was a good time for me to do
coke was i doing coke or did i consider
doing coke and i'm like not
at all and that was the last thing on my
mind you know i mean
and he's like really and i'm like yeah
no there's been nothing
no thoughts of it you know when i got
off the coke i got off the coke they did
me a [__] favor
that was a 28-year itch that was [__]
destroying me
and you know what like some people say
to you if you keep doing this
listen i was gonna die there was no i
was getting jolts in my spine
i was doing a bunch it was you know i
downplayed my addiction because it was a
long
time ago i downplay my addiction
but let me tell you something after i
got clean about eight months
i talked to this guy byron in la he's a
a drug
certification type guy that helps like
[__]
actors and people with a lot of [__]
money get clean i met him at the comedy
store
in 98 99 and then we you know he was
like a friend of ralphies
and i met him through ralphie and
after i got clean he reached out to me
and he's like hey man i always knew you
were [__] up on something
he goes i could see it all over your
face and stuff but i didn't know
you know what you were doing we went out
to lunch and uh
i told him the amounts i was doing he he
he was like what were you doing i grant
i was i go dog
i was doing a gram just to open up
you know once that wore off in an hour
i could do a gram in one [__] line so
once that wore
off in an hour i would sometimes hold
off but sometimes i get another [__]
gram
and i would do it in the other [__]
nose one shot deal
towards the end of my [__] before i
got clean
i was a mess there was heroin involved
there was cocaine involved
there was i don't know if there was no
there was no pills it was just basically
cocaine
and heroin i was going back and forth in
between the both of them and nobody knew
one person knew about the heroin he's
dead now so he can nev you know
he was the one that was mailing it to me
and none of my friends knew i mean it's
not something that you could tell rogan
or tom seguro or you know
anybody i wasn't saying [__] to anybody
but what's really funny is that
even my buddy in colorado was like
listen man i had to go back to therapy
and i'm like you went back it was that
bad and he goes yeah i was doing a
couple eight balls on the weekends and
[__] like that
so he asked me he said did you go to
therapy when you got clean
and i was like no i just journaled i
went online
and i looked for withdrawal symptoms of
cocaine and whatnot
and there weren't really any you know i
read up as much as i could there was
three aspects
of uh the rehab and that's
the mental the physical withdrawals
and then your spiritual you know that
this is all
things you got to cover
and again i'm not talking about [__]
a a or n a or nothing like that that's
always there that's always going to be
there
but i'm talking about the [__] how
therapy has helped me now like i never
thought that i would be here talking to
you [__] about therapy
i guys i would never even think about it
i got therapized one time i went to
therapy
one time i'll be strictly honest with
you guys when i was at bctc at the
halfway house
uh one of the stories i was telling on
uh
on whatever was that when i was a bctc
one of the things i forget to drop on
you [__] is that
i got one of the hot uas i gave when i
was telling you guys the story the other
day
what they did was they made me go to an
outpatient place
i forget what the name of it was it was
like six weeks and between me and you
it was a [__] ripoff like i never i
looked at that rehab and i was like that
rehab
did nothing for me it the only thing it
did was aggravate me and make me snort
more that's what that rehab did
that rehab was just like a [__] band
they didn't do anything
and i think the therapy that they were
using was getting me
[__] hot the lady there was it got to
the point where i wouldn't even say
nothing
i would just go there at night it was
like from six to nine with a little
breather in between
and i had to check there from the
halfway house we would go outside in
between the [__] break and
take a hit off a [__] joint and from
time to time she let me lick a little
monkey and she'd [__]
give me a [__] hooter unbelievable in
in the middle of [__] therapy we'd
walk out to say we were going to go
smoke the cigarette i didn't even smoke
back [__] then so
i didn't smoke in the [__] halfway i
didn't start smoking until i moved to
l.a in 97.
that's a complete different bag of
[__] worms but i never really liked
therapy i was like
what the [__] whenever they would do the
i didn't mind the
the group the [__] group because you
don't have to say [__]
you learn more from [__] listening i
dig that [__]
i didn't like the one-on-one with her
she would always pick a [__] and
she would instigate stuff and she would
bring up stuff that had nothing to do
with the [__] price of eggs
it's like i was watching the sopranos uh
years ago
and you know they got to the point where
dr melfi was telling tony that
maybe he wanted to [__] his mother that
all that that's when i you lose me
that's when you lose me when you stop
bringing your mother
and you start [__] uh talking about
you know
i mean no there's things that are on
your mind
and there's things that are in front of
you
i don't like picking [__] like i don't
like somebody saying to me well how did
you feel about this
in 2001 that that's dead i don't even
think about that [__]
you want me to dig it up to deal with it
but there's nothing to deal with i don't
even think about it so why am i dealing
with it
you understand trying to say to your
people well you know how did you react
to losing your daughter into
uh i reacted by [__] getting high
until the pain went away that's what
happened the pain went away i stopped
getting high and i moved the [__] on
that's what i think [__] happened
i don't know what else [__] could
have happened you just the pain ain't
there no more
the necessity is not there anymore and i
stopped doing the [__] coke
but i didn't think that me going to talk
to somebody was gonna i thought that it
would [__] aggravate me
i thought i would just get [__]
aggravated boy was i [__] wrong
you know three months ago two months ago
when i was going through my thing
of the panic attacks and whatever
somebody recommended to me
that i speak to somebody and i was like
it took me like a month to think about
it and i said you know what
a lot of people have gone through mental
health issues during this pandemic
you know it's just not me you know for
me not to [__] address this
that's the [__] felony when you don't
address it
let me do what i need to do you know i i
read about psycho
psychologists and i read about
everything and i just wanted to start
off with a simple therapist i didn't
want to [__]
pick my brain or get me [__] upset i
was just i just wanted to keep it
[__] light
i didn't want to go to anybody's office
i didn't want nobody you know
so i went on better help betterhelp.com
is [__] tremendous
somebody referred me to it a dear friend
that was going through a similar
situation
she told me to call and contact a
certain therapist
i went online i paid the fee i think
it's [__] eighty dollars a session or
something like that sixty dollars a
session
it doesn't kill you and if you want an
extra session a week it's 25 bucks
it it's not bad i went into it thinking
ah
and i gotta be honest with you i'm here
today because of that [__] third
voice
and i turned to a lot of friends of mine
i turned to people who really knew me
for help but i wanted an unbiased
opinion i wanted somebody who
did not see my face when we talked to
tell me what i was going through i
didn't want to get
or him to get [__] my videos or
from stand-up i didn't go in there with
that i wanted to talk to him as a normal
plain jane as i moved on with the
therapy
i opened up about comedy and what was
going on and blah blah blah
and now she still doesn't know who the
[__] i am
she calls me jose so that's great as
long as she calls me jose
that's great she doesn't know who the
[__] i am but i've opened up to her
not about like it wasn't like the
therapy from [__] uh
that rehab not at all this has been
i do the talking she asks a few
questions
and i [__] uh you know do the
homework she gives me a little bit of
homework
i write whatever things down i'll tell
you what man
i feel a lot [__] better i got it off
my chest
whatever i have i'm very vocal with my
wife
unlike how i used to be i'm very vocal
with my wife
i tell her whatever the [__] is going on
i tell her what i'm thinking
uh she knows about
[__] everything i came clean with her
before we moved here
and once we moved here she helped me out
listen man
what happened during the pandemic was
this and for me
it wasn't the booze or the reefer for me
towards the end i saw what happened to
me
you know nobody had a place to be
nobody had a place to be during the
[__] pandemic think about it
this is what happened nobody had a place
to be so if you started drinking at five
which i
got nothing but love for you this i have
a thousand friends
that have rules and i love you for
having those rules the same rules i have
but people who were drinking at five now
started drinking at one
they had nowhere to be i thought i did
the same [__] thing
you know i had nowhere to be what's
wrong with [__] getting [__] [__]
nizzled
i smoked so much during this [__]
pandemic
that it forced me to [__] quit like
that was the [__] like i couldn't
even like
this again like i'm gonna get high again
that's how high i was during the
pandemic i didn't want to feel i was
just like you guys
you know hey listen man i put my pants
on one leg at a time like you
[__]
there's nothing special about me i ain't
smarter than you [__] i
i'm not more educated than you
[__] in fact i'm more street
than you [__]
i just you know that's it it was just
the only thing available to me was the
reefer i didn't i didn't drink i think i
had
three drinks during the pandemic the
first drink i had was on rogan
on when i did the july the fourth
podcast with him on the jre
we did a shot of whiskey i didn't drink
but my smoking
was totally out of control forget about
the edibles
i was eating edibles i didn't even know
i had i was eating
you know we were eating 2 000 milligrams
at night no no
no i was doing a batch in the daytime
and a batch at night when i got here
august 19th last year i got here with a
jar
i had a [__] jar of abx 200 that he
just sent me
it was just a jar and i still remember
eating
four of them just to go to the [__]
pool when we were in somerset
four that's 800 milligrams at 11 o'clock
just to go [__] swimming and then at
night i would come back from the pool we
would go [__] look for furniture
whatever
before we moved into this house i was
eating
1600 milligrams a day a [__] thc
i was smoking maybe an eighth a day
and i was probably doing six to eight
footballs a day
i was the little xanax the appraisal
lamb whatever the [__] that is
that's not [__] good and i went off
those things
let me tell you something when i got
here my wife said something to me
my wife says you haven't been and i go
listen between the edibles
the [__] xanax the [__] reefer
the [__] anxiety i cannot take it no
more that is why i had the surgery
a lot of people the surgery was for me
to get clean from the xanax
so i took the [__] i i knew i was
gonna get surgery
i [__] did it perfectly i think i got
my whole life together
i think i had a long talk of myself like
maybe september 17th we went out to
dinner one night
and i realized how high it was during
[__] dinner and i go that's it
this goes to an end this is done
i came home i called my man byron
i told him byron i [__] uh
i started eating those little [__]
footballs
and i could kick them like i could kick
them but
when i went online they said you could
die xanax and alcohol
you could [__] have a reaction and
die if you just quit a cold turkey
and then i heard from a friend of mine a
chick
that she quit her xanax and one day she
just passed out in the kitchen
and she ended up going to the hospital
and they told us that you have to taper
off so
i got what they said i called my man
byron
byron said this is this could be really
easy
this could be really hard he goes i'm
going to give you a plan
and i want you to stick to it to the t
if you can't control yourself
then give the pills to your wife and i
did a tapering plan with him
he got me some amino acids you know i
had to order some amino acids i had to
order some calm
whatever i had to order a couple
nutrients he put me on
and i did exactly what he told me to do
he told me it's going to be a 90-day
taper and he goes you're not going to
take him at all in the daytime
that's why i started meditating that's
why i started doing little [__]
yoga stances you know when i had dr
belisse on the church
i didn't have dr belisse on there
because i didn't believe in breathing
or meditating you know the piece that i
have that piece from boss root and i
have it upstairs because i use it before
i go to bed at night
i have a mouthpiece from boss rooting
that i've been using just to
for my lung strength you know i started
using it for jiu jitsu
and i realized that it helps me out for
everything you know sometimes i hit the
bag and i put the mouthpiece in
it's [__] tough to do it takes a
while to get breathing but now since i
lowered my smoking the breathing is
tremendous but i just read
on yahoo that if you breathe through
that piece for five minutes
and take your blood pressure lowers your
blood pressure so what did i do i
[__] tried it
i got the [__] thing i got the blood
pressure machine i
did the blood pressure test it was 148
the first time
i [__] breathed on it for 10 minutes
i got back on the blood pressure machine
it was 128 it dropped 20 [__] points
so
breathing is key here when i put dr
belisse on that show a lot of people
were like that why'd you put dr police
on that show
and i told people i go i really believe
in the benefits of just breathing
breathing correctly that's why i had the
surgery on my nose yeah
i wanted to remove some of the old coke
rocks that were in there not letting me
breathe
and i was also addicted to afrin but
that's why i had the [__] nose
surgery
because i wanted to get back to
breathing naturally that that was very
interesting that we
we breathe naturally to like our teen
years
and then we break away from breathing i
look at my daughter's breathing
my daughter could run for [__] two
hours that little [__]
kid could run for two hours and she's
not breathing
mouth breathing or anything she's just
just living her [__] life
so i knew the breathing part of it was
important
and the anxiety i had i had to learn how
to just deal with it with breathing and
it was
tough guys it was very tough i'm not
gonna lie to you
i used to come in here and do downward
dogs
i used to come in here and just sit keep
the lights off
and just breathe and that helped me a
ton but when i got off the [__] xanax
i just stuck to byron's plan
that was it it went from he goes forget
about
doing six anymore let's get back to
basics why are you eating these and at
what time i go as soon as my heart beats
he goes no
i want you to breathe it out the first
time he goes what we're gonna do is this
we're not gonna do any
until three in the afternoon
and then if you need one pop one and
then
oh no not pop one papa half
he took me back that way and then he
goes at night i want you to eat a half
and just keep so i started with just i
went from six to maybe two
a day and then after two weeks he cut it
down to one
and then he kept me on one even though i
didn't want
my dog i don't even need these no more
he goes finish the [__] prescription
finish it he goes i want you to finish
it and go to a half
and then a quarter and i stayed with a
half like a month
and i think i stayed with the quarter
until
mid december and my goal was new year's
and i think i got off the [__] xanax
december 18th december 19th
and i had my surgery january 8 because i
didn't want to cross
the xanax with the [__] pain pills i
did my [__] work there was
no way i was gonna cross my xanax
addiction
with the pain pill addiction that wasn't
happening what i started doing also was
upping my [__] uh i said
[__] this edible [__] in the daytime it
ain't [__] working
so i'll start doing them at night that's
when i was drinking those teas i got
hooked on those tees
with the 900 [__] milligram i did
this correctly for the t
guys uncle joey's always thinking if
you're [__] hooked on something i'll
get you off
it's gonna be rough i always told you
[__]
that with those abx things you could get
off any [__] opiate
i told you [__] this and i
proved it to you i
proved it to myself with it so i started
in taking
larger amounts i mean i i passed [__]
abx i was probably doing 1600 milligrams
i was doing the whole [__] syringe
and a couple [__] edibles i was
putting melatonin in that [__]
this was michael jackson t to the
[__]
hilt but this is what i had to do to get
off the
and i didn't i didn't want to get a
stroke i didn't even need the xanax no
more i didn't want to get a stroke
and i kept popping a quarter a quarter a
quarter and i said let's see and i think
i saved like five of them
just in case i pussied out
i didn't eat one of those things until i
got back from the surgery
i needed one one day before [__] uh
pt
but that was the only xanax i had that
cross with the [__] pain pills
and i did the same thing with the
[__] pain pills once the pain pills i
started cutting them down
i [__] zipped up the edible intake
and [__] that's how i passed out at
night you just [__] go down you don't
even remember the xanax
you don't remember the pain pills the
oxies you don't remember [__]
and that was my recipe to get me off all
that [__]
but i still had a little residue
in me from the [__] xanax addiction
and i'm gonna tell you something i
didn't even i had no idea
until i started talking to my girl over
at betterhelp
that's when we started talking she goes
what else has been going on in your life
why did
why don't you want to do stand-up and
all this [__] and this is my main
when i called better help it wasn't for
drugs
it wasn't for edibles it wasn't for weed
it was none of that stuff
it was just to help me comprehend what i
was going through i didn't know what i
was going through i didn't know if it
was
the [__] the move i didn't know if i
was unhappy with
my new surroundings i had no [__]
idea what was going on i wanted somebody
to push me in the right direction and
from talking to her
after about three weeks i was like okay
i have to accept
all these new changes in my life there
was a thousand new [__] changes
from where i eat chinese to where i go
to the gym to
how i [__] to how i [__] pee you know
what floor i go on you know i used to
[__] with an open bathroom
now i [__] with a bathroom with no
windows big difference i got anxiety in
the bathroom with no [__] windows
so i had to switch upstairs to [__]
upstairs i you know these are all little
things
i had to go through and now 11 months
later do i feel [__] comfortable in
my own skin
yes i do do i feel comfortable in my
home
yes i do do i feel comfortable in my new
life yes i do
am i happy about not doing stand-up i am
i was thinking about it this weekend on
saturday morning
when i woke up saturday i came out my
daughter was watching tv downstairs
i usually i changed my whole life around
like one of the things i
definitely had to do was stop getting
coffee and jumping around the computer
it was [__] ruining my day and i had
no idea
just getting a cup of coffee and sitting
in front of the [__] computer
is no bueno for you i was getting so
what i started doing was getting a cup
of coffee
and going outside rain snow
shine sleet i'm out there if it's 10
degrees
i'm out there i don't smoke weed in the
morning i go out there with a cup of
coffee and i just focus on the trees
and i focus on breathing and that's
where i come up with the five things i'm
grateful for today
some days it's the sun some days it's
the trees
some days it's the little red bird i see
in the [__] tree
i'm always grateful for something it's
ever since ari told me to do that that's
helped
a ton realizing what you're grateful for
every day
and every day you're grateful for
something different some days you're
grateful that you have a big dick so
some days you're grateful thank god i
got a little dick i would have slammed
my dick in the [__] door if i would
have had an eight-inch dick you know
you got to be grateful for the little
things it's not your bank account it's
not
your car it's not a piece of ass it's
your surroundings
jesus it's a beautiful [__] day to be
you know i can't say that enough
to you [__] because i want you
to
you know how many people i hear call me
and go today was a bad day listen
when you really think about it it isn't
really a bad day unless you get hit by a
[__] car and fly 80 feet in the
[__] hand
think about how bad of a day did you
have your newspaper didn't come
you know my friend told me the other day
they sent me the wrong refrigerator
that's not a bad day
you got the [__] refrigerator you
know what i'm saying i mean we have to
start defining
what a bad day is and a great day is
this is the same [__] i was doing we
were all [__] doing this [__]
how bad of a [__] day was it bad
enough for you to [__] go have 50
[__] drinks come on
give me a [__] breather was it that
bad no you just had a hiccup in your day
we're all pre-programmed to have these
beautiful [__] days
they're not going to all be beautiful
you know many times i get up in the
middle of night and stub my [__] toe
and the wood goes in between your
[__] toe the fungi toenail that's
pain
and even then i don't [__] cry about
i just go ah
[__] it it could have been worse i could
have been walking down the street and a
safe could have hit me in the [__]
head you know
it's there's always something that's
worse
you know for you to [__] lose your
mind hey listen i'm from the same
[__] school of thought you know
i've had bad days and good days but
lately i've had a lot
better good days than bad days
and it took me 58 [__] years
to realize this [__] that your good days
are every [__] day
who gives a [__] so this guy was late
who cares it's not enough to ruin your
[__] day
ruin your day is finding your mother on
the floor dead with her armed purple
that's a that's a day ruiner right there
you know what i'm saying
[__] uh somebody's [__] in your mouth
that's a [__] somebody's sitting you
down and [__] in your mouth that's a
[__] bad day right there
but you know the oven came the other day
i was like
my oven [__] blew up about two weeks
ago my wife was cooking enchiladas and
the oven went down
so you know right away you're like an
oven we're gonna [__] be here
we're gonna have to rub sticks together
and [__] an oven you can't order a
[__] oven my wife found the place
that had ovens
in stock she goes for starters show me
what's in [__] stock
all right so we were panicking on friday
the oven was coming the oven's coming we
can't do nothing i'm like oh
whoa you got the world by the [__]
balls you can do whatever the [__] you
want the oven is not coming
the oven with they gave us the window
from two to six
that's four [__] hours we got to sit
here like a bumpy i go go run some
errands i'll sit here
and we'll switch you know then we my
wife had plans she's like the oven is
not gonna come to you know because
whenever you're waiting for a package it
always comes in that last [__] window
they tell you ten to two you're going to
get a ten to [__] two you're going to
get that 10 minutes to two
it's not ten to two they tell you ten to
two they're like the package will be
there from ten to two no one
it's gonna be here at 10 to two that's
what you're [__] trying to tell me
so we waited we're like what if this
[__] oven
comes at six o'clock well then you're
[__]
my wife is [__] we got a call the oven
came at [__]
four o'clock it took half hour my wife
and i i'm like it's not going to ruin
your day how is this going to ruin your
day
it's just a bump in it you had the
morning to do what you had to do you
have the afternoon to do what you got to
do
we have to start recognizing what the
[__] triggers are
was it that bad for you to get anxiety
and these are all the things that this
therapist helped me with
these are all the little [__] things
she didn't come in over all my life or
tell me i couldn't eat corn anymore you
know these people
you can't eat meat what the [__] are you
talking about
everything was beautiful in my life i
just had a little [__] hiccup
and i had to push through and
contacting somebody and talking to
somebody i got to be honest with you
was the best thing i've done in years i
feel a lot better i feel lighter
uh the medication they put me on seems
to be working i'm not losing my [__]
mind
i don't feel like killing myself i
haven't even had a negative [__]
thought
in fact i'm addressing negative thoughts
better i recognize them when they pop up
i know how to [__] deal with them and
these are all the tools they
just give you coping skills you know it
has such a [__]
stigma therapy it has such a bad stigma
to it
even towards me i had a bad [__]
stigma but after a few weeks i used to
get anxiety
waiting to get on the phone with her
like waiting to [__] get on the phone
with her i would get like a little bit
of anxiety and then i told her once
i told her right i go you know i get
anxiety before i talk to you
she goes do this this this this she told
me what to do
now i look forward to [__] seeing her
you know i was getting
the only thing i'm having i'm still
having a little problem with
is the social anxiety i'm still having
my problems with that
the numbers are going back up now the
[__] delta variant the chinese
variant the cuban variant
they're gonna listen they don't want
this [__] thing to go away so
you know they want everybody to get
vaccinated they don't want this thing to
go away
i still have little issues socially
you know like i'm looking forward to go
to guns and roses on the 11th and 12th
of september
you know i don't care how many people
there if somebody has tickets for the
fit that met life
i'm not saying i'm not gonna go but i'll
consider going i think we have plans
that day already
but i would consider going uh
stand up i'll tell you what guys
i was a little burnt up on stand up i
was burnt
what i did was i recognized about the
stand up what was getting to me
and uh i've been doing a lot of [__]
writing
the last five months i've been doing a
lot of writing
between notes for the book for erica you
know looking into my life
i've been doing a lot of [__] writing
and
one thing i've noticed in the journaling
one thing that's kept me alive
has been the journaling and making new
discoveries about myself
you know and one thing about the
stand-up is
i wrote out all the things that bothered
me about stand up what was going on you
know
and i think the thing that bothered me
the most was this
before 2012 2011 before i popped up on
the board
you got to remember guys i had been a
comic already for
13 14 years
was there any success yes i had my
bright spots
you know i had my bright spots as an
actor
i hadn't had any bright spots as a
comedian i felt that nobody really
wanted me as a comic
but i also felt that i wasn't given a
100 percent of what i could do
my comedy changed when i went from
zingers
to storytelling i became a better comic
and i had more my mind was more involved
in it
i'm not a good writer i'll be the first
one to raise my hand
and say i'm not a great comedy writer
anthony jeselnik rogan
bill burr bill burr's mind for comedy is
brilliant uh
as a couple comics uh john mulaney
i'm a fan of their writing i've never
been a fan of my writing i am who i am
and i'm i'm proud that i have my own
style
but there were things that stand up
weren't agreeing with me i think the
number one thing that was bothering me
was
waking up in a hotel room on a saturday
morning
i didn't really dig that no more i
didn't dig the
you know i like [__] eating breakfast
out i [__] loved that
i loved going to a different town and
eating their restaurant you know like
their local restaurants not a chain
but like family restaurants i loved all
that [__]
but i hated waking up in a hotel on
saturday mornings
i hated that whole [__] day you know
then i started doing theaters and it
made me it forced me to travel on
saturdays
which was interesting at first but after
a while it burns you out a lot more
taking those if you gotta take a plane
on thursday
saturday and sunday you're [__] burnt
by the time you get back on sunday your
back feels like
because you've been sitting for three
[__] days you flew there
you know you either drove to the gig
like when we did new york
we had to get up the next morning at 10
and be on a [__] four-hour train to
boston by the time i got to boston
my back was [__] wrecked you know it
was just [__] and wrecked
so all those things i didn't like i
didn't like i don't want to do saturdays
no more
so if i do comedy i got to do it
differently i didn't like saturdays
anymore
i don't think i could do a late [__]
show on a friday and saturday number one
at 10 o'clock show
that's dead so if i get back into comedy
it would have to be during the week
thing
an early show you know two shows during
the week tuesday and wednesday
um
it's not my life anymore it would be a
hobby
it would be a hobby i would start off
strong with it
you know just to get my material back my
half hour my 45 minutes
which i have been making notes by the
way if you know anything about me
i have not lost my sense of humor you
know and i have not lost
my uh saying [__] you know
you know like little [__] dirty
things to myself and writing them down
i'm still one of those dudes i'm making
notes i looked at my comedy the other
day
i probably got 22 minutes of material
once i write it all out but
i'm not in the mood to [__] go out
there yet when i'm in the mood and i'm
ready
you'll be the first to [__] know but
that's this was all little things
that were contributing to my anxiety and
i had no [__] idea
until i spoke to somebody so what am i
telling you today on a monday morning
that
listen guys we all have [__] little
quirks going on with us and now more
than ever with this pandemic
you know we forgot how to act
we're not acting right right now a lot
of people are acting [__] crazy
planes you read about it you hear about
it i heard about a fist fight at a
[__] nice restaurant the other day
a friend of mine told me he was at a
restaurant the [__] lady got up
and smacked the waitress right here in
[__] northern new jersey a friend of
mine was at
in hobo i mean it's just it's just crazy
the things you hear
and we're all going through our
different things and it's going to get
worse
you know the rent [__] things are
coming to an end
all these things you know a lot of
people having a hard time
listen man i i'm the type of guy that
i dealt with [__] all my life and move
slowly this pandemic
[__] me up a little bit i mean i've
gone through the mill i've gone through
it
with my mother i divorced the addiction
i
you know i lived in a rocket ship i mean
i've [__] been through
hell and back but this pandemic [__]
me up a little bit
it showed us things that we didn't need
to see
it showed a lot of us things that we
didn't need to see i became an only
child again
you know i was raised an only child and
then somewhere throughout life i had
forgotten all about that
this pandemic reminded me i was an only
child
it got me back to talking to myself and
thinking to myself
but in a good way it got me to open up
my eyes a lot of people have opened up
their eyes
how many people are not going back to
their [__] jobs
how many people are just saying [__]
i'm switching careers
you know and in a way this is what
happened to me also
i just switched careers i like
podcasting i still like acting
but to stand up just the whole thing
wasn't rubbing me the right way i needed
this break there's nothing
wrong with taking a break there's
nothing wrong with coming out of the
[__] closet
closet and that's what i did
i came out of the closet not as a gay
man
i'm identifying as a man that doesn't
want to do comedy no more
i don't want you [__] to think
that joey just said he came out of the
closet no
i'm not in that closet at all i would i
would love to be gay i can't you know
what i'm saying i would love to hold the
man's hand and
look him in the eye and say suck my dick
but i still haven't come up with the
heart to do that so
for right now i'm not coming out of the
gate closet i'm just coming out of the
closet that i was unhappy i was unhappy
about a lot of things
and i didn't [__] know him and i'm
happy i made the [__] adjustments you
know
so what i'm trying to say is i'm happy i
started talking to somebody
if you're going through something listen
man and
i've looked they have adjustable prices
for your income
you know like you write down what you
make a year and they'll work with here
i'm sure if you tell these people you're
on unemployment they have a special
unemployment rate for you you know
12 or whatever the [__] it is this ain't
gonna put you out
but it's not worth going through life
twisted
for you not to spend 25 bucks to talk to
somebody for a half hour
i mean my meetings are only a half hour
that's it i can't
i can't talk to somebody longer than
that a half hour and that's [__] it
you know
we got everything covered in a half hour
i usually jump on the phone with the
mondays
you know like this week is 9 30 in the
morning on monday i'll be out the phone
with her by 10 o'clock
and i enjoy the conversation i write
down my notes
she gives me a little homework now when
i talk to a monday the homework will be
ready
and i feel a lot happier you know a
couple people my friend derek a couple
guys have said that my snap is coming
back on the podcast and i gotta be
honest here i'm feeling it i'm feeling
uh
i'm feeling the change coming off me so
i want to thank you guys
for having my back during this whole
time you just got to turn your back on
me
and a lot of you didn't a lot of you
knew i was a wounded [__] deer
and you said where's this [__]
gonna take it you saw me go through my
changes myself
i didn't [__] just sit here and wait
this on me
i did the work you know i knew i had to
quit reefer i quit the reefer i
restructured my edible [__] game you
know
i came out with a new bag of [__]
weed which you know i did different
things
and then ft you know i'm writing this
[__] book you know with erica
this is you know writing a book is
[__]
rough it's rough to drag yourself to the
mud
but i'm doing it i'm doing it maybe
that's part of the anxiety
i don't care i'm doing it you know i was
having a hard time
going through guitar lessons some weeks
like that's how high my anxiety was now
we talk all the [__] time
i play every night i mean don't let this
[__] weigh you down
and you know if you're not right like i
knew i wasn't right i knew
since i started the podcast with mike i
knew that
a piece of me was missing and i just had
to
you know work through it you know i i
wish
there's times i'm like [__] i didn't i
wish i didn't do the podcast
in october november and december but i
needed it to get back to where the [__]
i was going and little by little
i'll get all my [__] tools back and
to be honest i'm at 95
now i feel that much [__] better
and it was the work in a [__] program
that was it i didn't do nothing
spectacular i didn't go to any [__]
rehab i didn't hire a [__] uh
uh what do you call as a sober buddy you
know i didn't do none of that [__]
i didn't want to go through any of that
[__] i did it all myself i got myself
in this mess i'll get myself out of this
[__] mess you know
i sent byron a couple bucks he didn't
want them he wanted [__] uh
t-shirts and [__] so he wanted to make a
trade so when i called him
and he put me on the plan for the
[__] uh
for the xanax it was the best thing in
the world because he
made me jump off you know he told me
some [__] too that
kept me from jumping off the ledge that
i had no [__] idea
you know so i'm happy this all worked
out how it did
i'm happy i [__] uh i started the
podcast again
i'm happy that i'm here [__] talking
to you [__] twice a week
and i'm just happy i'm happy and i want
you [__] to be happy
and like i said if i got caught up in
the [__] xanax and if i'm aware of a
lot of the stuff
i can't imagine what some people did
that aren't aware how fast
things go from a to [__] z i'm just
happy that i didn't get into alcohol or
coke or any of that [__]
and that this was a [__] easier
transition
that's it [__] it's monday it's
gonna be a [__] great week
i don't know if uh how i'm gonna look on
[__] wednesday
for you [__] uh
this afternoon they're about to tap me
[__] open again on this side here
i'm dreading it but what am i gonna do i
need this infection to go away
so i could be happy i think this is
affecting my heart
and uh it needs to be [__] done
i'm scared but i'll go out of respect
for you guys you know what i'm saying
you just can't talk to talk you got to
walk the [__] walk so
that's it and that's that i'll be back
wednesday with you [__]
on the joint for another tip top magoo
session
today was a little [__] weird i
wanted to talk to you about this and get
this out of the way
because i've seen the amount of people
that have reached out
with that problem one guy on patreon
says he's been sober for nine [__]
months that i helped him
and he had a baby so you know things
like that
[__] always get my dick hard that
somebody actually got sober
you know we talked a couple times i
talked to a couple guys on patreon that
were having a hard time
i'm happy they used the dear abby thing
and we got it all out of the way
but that's it and that's that you bad
[__] i hope you enjoyed
yourselves on monday
i'll be back wednesday thank you for
[__] going to
the ice cream shop and purchasing
laughing gas
it's good [__] weed somebody asked me
to give it a review the other day
i'm going to be as honest i can with you
know what the review is
it's good [__] [__] i'm really happy
with it
i would love to come on here and break
it down for you guys well the th
listen it's good [__] i've been telling
you guys for years
that i smoke great [__] and i can't
believe the ice cream shop
and ziki put this [__] strain
together it's tremendous
i love it i love what it does i love how
it works
and i'm [__] proud of ziki i'm proud
of joe
and i'm proud of the ice cream shop and
we're going through this together
but it couldn't go possible without you
guys and you guys believing in [__]
my weed uh prowlers you know you guys
know when it comes to reefer
i ain't [__] around i love you
[__] have a great week
and now for a word for my [__]
sponsor
jack aye you bad [__] i hope
you enjoyed the podcast today
i don't know what the [__] i was talking
about maybe you guys will figure it out
it's monday that's what happens when you
get too [__] stoned at night
but i love you guys and that's all that
matters that i check in with you every
monday and wednesday
so you know that life is tip top magoo
the joint is brought to you by
magnesium breakthrough listen if you're
ignoring how you feel
you need to listen to this fatigue
anxiety headaches
all might come back to one thing you're
not getting enough magnesium
magnesium breakthrough is to cure
magnesium is an amazing mineral not only
does it help you sleep
it also helps reduce stress maintain
regular heartbeat
and it boosts your immunity i've been on
this for like two months
and i'll tell you what i'm sleeping like
a [__] bag
when i go upstairs at 11 30 i hit that
crib
and it's nappy new new time no matter
what and when i wake up in the morning
i feel like i got sleep i mean you guys
see me every morning on patreon
when i wake up i'm looking like [__]
uh you know like a movie star
and that's all because of sleep rest and
water
eighty percent of the population is
magnesium deficit
deficient if you don't get the right
amounts you're eventually going to end
up
at the doctor's office listen i'm amazed
on how much better i sleep
and how rested i feel in the morning
plus since i've been taking it i feel
more relaxed and peace throughout the
day
magnesium breakthrough is the only
organic supplement
that includes seven unique forms of
magnesium
it works fast i do it about 30 minutes
before i hit the crib
and i sleep like a baby nappy nunu
just for the joint family go to
magbreakthrough.com
joey use promo code joey10
during checkout to save 10 that's
magbreakthrough.com
joey e a m-a-g-b-r-e-a-k
through t h r o u g h
dot com slash joey and use code joey
for 10 off and when you see the sandman
tell him uncle joey sent you the joint
is also
brought to you by relief band listen
a third of americans suffer from nausea
are you one of them
get relief banned i didn't know what it
was i had no idea
my agent fanny sent it to me i thought
it was a doctor's office because i got
it right before i had surgery
and i'll tell you what it took care of
my nausea
tip top magoo relief man is the number
one fda cleared
anti-nausea wristband that has been
clinically proven to relieve
and prevent nausea and vomiting the
product is 100 percent
drug free and it doesn't make you drowsy
and it has zero
count them zero side effects this is the
kind of thing
that they use at hospitals and oncology
clinics
no no you can get it sent right to your
house through uncle joey here's how it
works relief ban
stimulates a nerve in the wrist that
travels to the part of the brain
that controls nausea then it blocks the
signal from your brain
sending it to your stomach telling you
that you're sick
this is science relief man is the only
over-the-counter wearable band
that has been used in hospitals and
oncology clinics
to treat nausea and vomiting i love this
thing
it bailed me out a couple times so do me
a favor right now if you're having
surgery
or you're suffering from nausea or other
things
get the relief band relief band has an
exclusive offer
just for uncle joey's joint listeners
you ready
go to reliefband.com use promo code joey
j-o-e-y
you'll receive 20 off
20 off plus free shipping and a no
questions asked 30 day money back
guarantee
this is what i love about this product
the most the 30 day money back guarantee
that tells you they believe in that
product so head over
to relief band r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com
and use our promo code joey for 20 off
get it for your grandmother get it for
your father get it for your uncle
you know your mom has nausea forget
about the alka celsius
this is the way to go reliefband.com
use promo code joey and receive 20 off
plus free shipping and no questions
asked on a 30-day
money-back guarantee reliefband.com
use promo code joey 20 off
and get relief and you won't have puke
breath no more
i love you guys i want to thank
reliefband.com and i want to thank
magnesium breakthrough or better yet
magbreakthrough.com
joey i want to thank both companies but
most importantly
i want to thank you guys for having my
back listening and supporting the joint
patreon anything else i might be doing i
love you guys
have a great week enjoy your monday stay
black
and we'll be back wednesday rockin
tip top magoo there's still some reefer
left
over at the ice cream shop there's still
some laughing gas
sign up at laffinggas.com all the wii
stores that it's getting sold that is
gonna be up on the instagram page
i love you guys have a great monday have
a great week stay black
and we'll be back wednesday
there you go [__] go wash your
[__] i love you
[Music]
um
so
[Music]
foreign
you